un parfum de thaïlande a flotté sur
conflans sainte honorine ce samedi 14
janvier à gala de muay thaï était
organisé pour la cinquième fois la
capitale de la batellerie
pour ce rendez vous plus de 1000
personnes ont fait le déplacement pour
voir ce sport de combat qu'ils mènent
les techniques ou de pieds poings genoux
coudes et les projections le public est
réceptif toujours à contretemps c'est la
cinquième édition
et puis le tout le monde et la tournée
présent c'est un paquebot que je
travaille depuis quelques temps
maintenant et donc j'ai pris soin de
préparer ces combats minutieusement donc
là ce soit y aura du spectacle pour la
première fois un combat féminin pour la
ceinture wmc était programmée dans
l'enceinte entre la française myriam
jedidi la belge walesa de veille est
tricolore en brassière noir l'emportent
dans cet affrontement
je suis évidemment un super contente
pendant de ma prestation est contente
d'avoir fait aux pisseurs plaisir au
public par n'ont apparemment ça leur a
plu le feu qui m'encourage ça m'arrivait
ajustements à monter le rythme chez les
hommes en full contact michel lopes da
veiga originaire de sartrouville cinq
fois champion de france champion
d'europe et champion du monde en titre
s'est imposé contre william hill mais
d'issy les moulineaux
je conclus pierrât ap ap un adversaire
très coriace m'a donné du fil à retordre
et ça je le savais depuis le début
non franchement bas je sais content moi
mais voilà en falloir que je travaille
beaucoup de choses à l'entraînement
les bénéfices de cette soirée
permettront d'acheter du matériel pour
développer le muay thaï dans les
quartiers le montant exact n'a pas
encore été communiquée